[Music]
on this Wednesday night cracking down on
members of Iran's regime a senior
Iranian official believed to be living
in Canada our officials are just not
taking this issue as as seriously as
they should his role in Tan's human
rights abuses a global news
exclusive the crisis deepens in what the
UN is now calling an apocalyptic
situation as Israel's Army moves deeper
into Southern Gaza plus American Aid to
Ukraine under threat and now they're
willing to literally kneecap Ukraine on
the battlefield the Congressional vote
jeopardizing Ukraine's ability to fight
Russia and a writer who made Millions
laugh we got God who is
black a Norman Year's daring comedy
revolutionized TV sitcoms by taking on
every
taboo global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
Canada has launched a deportation case
against a man who is believed to have
served as a senior official in the
Iranian government he's one of nine
cases heading heading to court testing
new sanctions that banned high ranking
members of Iran's Hardline regime from
Canada those sanctions were brought in
following Iran's brutal Crackdown on
dissident after the death of Masa amini
in police custody and there are concerns
more members of the repressive regime
could be living here in Canada Jeff SLE
has our top story tonight
Jeff Donna in 2016 Sayed salmon samani
became a senior minister in Iran's
government now global news has learned
he's apparently living in
Canada for years he was a prominent
voice for Iran's repressive regime SED
salmon samani spokesperson and Deputy
Minister for Iran's interior Ministry in
charge of the country's Security Forces
including its notorious morality police
used to crack down on human
rights Sani routinely defended his
regime's record including at the United
Nations human rights are a huge
consideration for the Iranian government
Sani told the UN in November 2019 now a
few years later an Iranian man with the
same name and birth date is believed to
be living in the Toronto area so a
person like this is not the kind of
person that should be welcomed into this
country this lawyer and human rights
activist shows a quick Google search
yields dozens of results highlighting
sani's connection to Iran's regime but
however he apparently got in somani May
soon be forced out Canada's Border
Services Agency is now seeking the
deportation of an Iranian man named
Sayed Salman somani it's the first case
to be heard under new sanctions that
baned senior members of the Iranian
regime from
Canada those sanctions were introduced
last year after Iran's morality police
killed masa amini for showing her hair
in public her death became a rallying
cry Iran cracked down killing hundreds I
think Canada's probably one of the safe
havens for Affiliates of Iran's regime
so they see it as as an easy country to
get into because our officials are just
not taking this issue as as seriously as
they should but the new sanctions are
starting to show their teeth sani's case
is the first of nine deportation
proceedings now underway another 141
investigations are ongoing and 78
Iranians have been prevented from
entering Canada Community activists call
that the tip of the iceberg this is just
the beginning really the scale of this
is so great and there's very little
faith that actually this is going to
become a safe country the sonani
deportation hearing is scheduled to
begin here in Toronto on January 3rd
Donna all right Jeff simple in Toronto
thanks Israel's prime minister claims
the military is closing in on the home
of the top Hamas commander yaha sinir in
southern Gaza a man Israel describes as
the architect of the October 7th attacks
and tens of thousands of civilians in
Gaza who were told to move South are now
caught in a
catastrophe Israeli bombardments have
hit Rafa on the border with Egypt the
injured including children are being
rushed to Rafa's Kuwaiti Hospital UNICEF
says there are no safe zones the
intensified fighting in the South means
Distributing Aid throughout Gaza is next
to Impossible deepening the humanitarian
crisis and today the UN Secretary
General invoked a rarely used clause and
a push for the security Council to call
for a humanitarian ceasefire and to meet
as early as this week Crystal ganing
Reports day and night there is chaos and
bloodshed multiple strikes were reported
on Rafa in southern Gaza Wednesday night
Rescuers were forced to search for
survivors by flashlight the building
still burning above them I think we've
all had this image of of international
law and order be completely shattered in
this we have been screaming for eight
weeks about what a perilous and and
horrific experience people in Gaza are
facing the Norwegian Refugee council is
one of many a agencies with staff
members on the ground trying to survive
while trying to help the wounded
displaced and those unsure of what to do
or where to go this 11-year-old girl was
searching a hospital in hunas for her
dad her family was separated after a
strike
I missed you I missed you too baby Mia
Linberg endured nearly two months in
Gaza as a hostage she says she's not
okay but well enough considering it's
very important for me to say that even
though me and my mother and my aunt
returned and there are a lot of people
who have returned and it's still
important to fight for the people who
are still there the UN Human Rights
agency describing Gaza as apocalyptic
the safety of the more than 100
remaining hostages is a major
concern intense Urban combat is now
underway as Israel's war against Hamas
stretches into its second month Medical
Teams say they can't cope now we working
in this emergency department uh with
only four doctors in the regular days we
have around 35 to 40 doctors now we have
only four doctors as calls for a
ceasefire grow louder survival for those
in Gaza is becoming more of a game of
chance Crystal Ganson Global News
London a pivotal election is underway at
the Assembly of First Nations Chiefs
from across the country are choosing a
new National chief after the last one
Rosanne archal was removed in June after
intense turmoil in the organization
there were six candidates in the running
to replace her when voting got underway
earlier today our chief political
correspondent David Aken is keeping an
eye on that vote
David right Donna we've got from 6 down
to two voting's been going on for 4
hours multiple ballots have happened and
right now Cindy Woodhouse she is the afn
regional chief for Manitoba she's in the
lead but she's only got 54% and when I
say only has 54% you need 60% of the
votes cast to win so Cindy Woodhouse at
54% right well not right behind her but
it ways back David Pratt he is the vice
chief of the Federation of the uh
Sovereign Indian nations that's a
Saskatchewan base group he's at 35% of
the vote Sheila North is eliminated she
got about 10% on the last ballot and
Sheila North just a few minutes ago in
her concession speech through her
support behind David Pratt but do the
math that won't end up to 60 but still
Cindy Woodhouse needs a bit more points
so uh we're going to have another ballot
could be voting a little later on maybe
a couple more hours uh uh to see if
Cindy Woodhouse becomes National Chief
okay and David are there common themes
the candidates are pitching priorities
they all agree on they are so it's going
to be Woodhouse or Pratt and both of
them in their speeches said they really
want to revitalize the afn it's been a a
bit of an organization under stress
after rosan archal was essentially
removed so they want to make sure that
the afn is seen to be more effective at
advocating for First Nations communities
across the country if Cindy Woodhouse
wins she's vowed that policing in First
Nations communities will be her top
priority
Donna in Ottawa thank you the defense
minister Mr Bill Blair says he is
setting up a review board to analyze the
culture Education and Training at
Canada's two military
colleges and in particular the board's
seven members will consider
long-standing cultural concerns in the
military College environment including
misogyny and discrimination and the
ongoing incidents of sexual misconduct a
recent statistics cada survey found
reports of sexual assault within the
Canadian Armed Forces increased
significantly in 2022 despite Promises
of Reform the review board will have a
year here to deliver a report and
recommendations new report from Canada's
electronic spy agency warned cyber
threats including deep fakes generated
by artificial intelligence could have an
impact on Canada's next federal election
it says China and Russia are already
targeting elections in other countries
and Canada needs to be ready Abigail
Bean looks at what we need to
know according to the communications
security establishment or csse cyber
threats targeting elections around the
world are on the rise and Canada is not
immune in the upcoming election we can
expect to see possibly more cyber threat
activities targeted towards Canada bad
guys are getting better at hiding their
tracks we don't know who is responsible
for 85% of global attacks last year but
where they can be identified the CSE
says Russia and China are to blame I
think most Canadians if they knew that
it was it was a hostile foreign state
for example that was responsible um for
the publication of of these fakes um I
think that'll help Canadians understand
you know that they are that that people
are trying attempting to deceive them
and and to misinform them what's up
internet deep fakes generated by
artificial intelligence and becoming
increasingly indistinguishable from the
real thing we're entering an era in
which our enemies can make it look like
anyone is saying anything at any point
in time like this video that isn't
actually former president Barack Obama
this is something that we're predicting
will happen in the next election because
of the the availability of generative Ai
and the idea that this is something for
us to be concerned about and mindful of
and educate ourselves those attacks on
elections can be wide ranging anything
from hacking systems to stealing voter
information to otherwise influencing
election outcomes Abigail bman Global
News Ottawa the Bank of Canada is
holding its key interest rate steady at
5% the Central Bank says higher interest
rates are slowing spending and helping
bring down inflation but there could be
hikes in the months ahead
they haven't won the fight on inflation
so they're very careful in what they
mentioned it's pretty clear from you
know all the indicators uh at hand that
they won't need to do that weaker growth
and a cooling job market suggest demand
isn't outpacing Supply in the economy
and some forecasters say the next move
in 2024 could be a rate cut the federal
government is set to announce long-
awaited plans for an emissions cap on
the oil and gas industry tomorrow a
source tells Global News it will be a
cap and trade system and will take
effect by 2030 requiring a significant
cut in emissions it's expected to Grant
oil and gas producers some flexibility
by allowing them to buy offsets or pay
into a decarbonization fund if they
exceed the emissions cap America's
support for Ukraine hanging by a shred
coming up a pivotal vote in Washington
that could cut the flow of weapons to
ke
look I know we have our divisions at
home let's get past them this is
critical Petty partisan angry politics
can't get in the way of our
responsibility as a leading nation in
the world and literally the entire world
is watching that's US President Joe
Biden making a last ditch plea for
Congress to approve billions more in
military aid for Ukraine it didn't work
tonight the the legislation was blocked
by Republicans who were pressing for
more money to clamp down on immigration
at the US border with Mexico without
continued American Aid Ukraine's future
hangs in the balance far Nasser
explains it's a vote the US President
says will go down in history and
lawmakers will be judged harshly
Republicans and Congress was willing to
give Putin the greatest gift he could
hope for McConnell President Biden
turned up the pressure on Congress to
pass a multi-billion dollar foreign aid
package that has been deadlocked for
months the $16 billion funding bill
combines Aid to both Ukraine and Israel
along with funding for Taiwan and money
allocated to US border security but
Republicans are demanding more in return
a stricter immigration policy pinning a
foreign policy priority against the
domestic migrant crisis there will never
be a bill I'll vote for to help other
countries who are very deserving until
we control our own border that's
completely broken if Putin takes Ukraine
he won't stop there if Russian President
Vladimir Putin attacks a NATO Ally Biden
says the us would have to get involved
then we'll have something that we don't
seek and that we don't have today
American troops fighting Russian troops
we're just giving Ukraine enough to
survive we need to give them enough so
they can actually win and be decisive on
the battlefield Ukrainian president
vomir zalinsky addressed G7 leaders
virtually Wednesday morning we have a
realistic EXO strategy and it is our
efforts with your support of go that can
ensure Ukraine's success on the ground
in keev an anxious
atmosphere this man's friend recently
died in the
fighting he says every day of delay in
America means a loss of human lives in
Ukraine with the funding bill being
blocked in the US Senate it's unlikely
for Ukraine to get that additional
American Aid by the end of the year
which is what President Biden wanted
Congress goes on holiday break at the
end of next week Donna all right for our
ner in Washington
thanks still ahead how Norman Lear broke
boundaries in TV
[Music]
comedy he once said the soundtrack of
his life has been laughter Norman Lear
who lived to be 101 spent his life
creating TV characters that made
millions of people laugh Archie Bunker
ma The Jeffersons sitcoms like them had
never been made before misogyny racism
homophobia Lear tackled it all one TV
critic says Lear almost single-handedly
transformed our idea of what kinds of
stories TV was capable of telling Mike
DeRay on how Norman Le found humor in
everything eyes like us we had it made
those were
it took 3 years for Norman Lear to
convince a network to air All in the
Family you are a me a groundbreaking
sitcom about a bluecollar bigot and his
family keep your white astronauts like I
already proved to you we got God who is
Black well the only answer to that
is it was controversial but also
different from anything else on TV and
it became the number one show in America
it'll always be remembered because it
dealt with with real people who were
facing real issues nothing was off
limits and uh everything was based on
the truth a slew of hit spin-offs
offering the same combination of
onliners and social conflict soon
followed including the Jeffersons and
Different Strokes let's shake hands huh
like uh a brother I've been practicing
Willis
no wonder they can't play basketball he
was Fearless in 1972 months before the
US Supreme Court ruled on Row versus
Wade mod became the first TV character
to have an abortion just tell me Walder
that I'm doing the right thing not
having the baby and then in the 1980s he
stepped away from Hollywood to focus on
political activism and fight the
influence of the religious right I think
of myself by the way as a bleeding
conservative you will not mess with my
Bill of Rights he did eventually return
to his roots in TV working well into his
late 90s the topics he so deafly poked
fun at 50 years ago religion racism gay
rights still is relevant today as they
were then finding another Norman Lear to
tell those stories won't be easy Mike
drle Global News
Toronto she's shattering records with
her World Tour is the most streamed
artist in 2023 and now Taylor Swift is
times person of the year the magazine
calls her the master Storyteller of the
modern era Eric senson looks at what
makes the 33-year-old singer songwriter
so
unique we're about to go on a little
adventure together she is the world's
biggest star with a fan base as devoted
and large as any in history but Taylor
Swift is not the traditional symbol of
power and political influence associated
with time person of the year but that
underestimates says time what she's
achieved in a year of division and
darkness in the world we picked a choice
someone who represents Joy someone who's
bringing light to the world someone
who's taken her own story and made it
big enough for everyone Swift's music
and concerts have made her a billionaire
her romance with Travis Kelce has given
a boost to America's ultimate culture
Champion football she is a cultural
Juggernaut in terms of moving the needle
wherever she wants wants to go in
politics in football in the music
industry in fashion it woke me up from
constantly feeling like I was fighting
for people's respect Swift says her
journey to the top meant taking back her
music and career from industry
Executives who' controlled her from the
time she was a teenager at a time when
our society was absolutely obsessed with
the idea of having perfect young female
role models she has been empowering for
women and girls
I feel really good about not feeling
muzzled some call her fans a cult and
dismiss her impact is not much Beyond
how people feel she's just a pop star
and she's this young woman right but I
think it shows kind of the cultural
influence of her it kind of challenges
some of the problematic ideas we have
about girls and girlhood um within
Society along with Beyonce it has been
the year of women at the top making
themselves heard and their influence may
only grow Swifts get out the vote Drive
led to record us voter registration this
fall I want to do this I need to be on
the right side of history and if she can
mobilize the swifties who are old enough
to vote who knows what 2024 will bring
from 2023 is Person of the Year Eric
senson Global News Toronto and that is
global national for this Wednesday I'm
Donna freezen tonight's your Canada is a
cat who took his future into his own
hands or pause coko was stuck on top of
a utility poll in Newland until this
happened she don't scratch
you oh my God he took a flying leap
evading the arms of that newfinland
power worker who was trying to rescue
him Coco's owner says he is just fine
though that leap may have used up one of
his Nine Lives thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye
has the
treat